look at the culmination of that now for
the past few presidents the you said
this is our president this is our
president
the the thing that people have been
screaming for the last decade or so is
not my president yeah not my president
yeah and that's on the left and the
right whether it's trump or biden or
even obama sad reality is guys this is
the president of the united states so my
humble place is as a i suppose somebody
from the anglophile as we would call it
the the five eyes countries uh the
english-speaking democracies they share
all their
the five eyes refers to the fact that
they all share the deepest military
intelligence so it's america
britain canada australia new zealand
um that the plea would be that we need
and long for a coherent america
for your sakes
um because i admire you that's i say but
also because the world needs a good cop
in very dangerous times your enemies are
not your fellow americans surely they're
the people who want to destroy your